one of the most critical parts of making
a superhero movie Singh is the film
score we've got four-time Academy Award
nominee Danny Elfman here to talk about
crafting the sound of a super team
really the whole crazy jigsaw puzzle of
Justice League was how to incorporate
old and new and make it all work
together it was my feeling when it came
on the project that DC already had these
really cool elements and that they
shouldn't be ignored that we should pull
it all together we should make it part
of the DC legacy so right in the
beginning the feeling was for these
different characters it's like okay
we're gonna touch on bits of all these
different things why don't we go back
even as far as John Williams Superman
theme because it's a beautiful classic
theme it's a gem that's been lost and
hidden so to take that and twist it
around for me is like real pleasure
because I like taking themes and like
bending them and turning them so I did
use it but I used that in a way that
won't necessarily be expected and so
that was probably the most fun I had in
the whole project was doing that a
little bit of a twist
[Music]
[Music]
I acknowledged honza's Wonder Woman
theme because it's a really catchy
melody and it's like okay I found a
great moment for that
[Music]
giving fans these things is a great
pleasure for them tying things together
is a pleasure for them it gives like a
little bit of a thrill when it came to
Batman it was kind of easy we define two
or three moments where we were really
doing Batman 89 so to speak like right
out of it just like fan moments but then
everywhere else it was just
that's what Batman's harmonies are
that's what his melody is I wasn't even
consciously trying to evoke 89 at all
because part of us from 89 part of its
from 92 and part of it is actually what
continued on even afterwards which never
really changed and so that just was a
continuation of the same thing except
for these moments that were like okay
nail it right here you know and do a
dead-on rendition for these like 20
seconds or something like that and so
there's a few of those in there the rest
is more subliminal and it's just what
Batman's music is
[Music]
for Aquaman flash and cyborg I didn't
want to introduce a complex theme
because there's just too many themes you
know in other words you really can't
have six themes running in a movie or
you're never not going to be playing
somebody's theme and it's gonna get
really tedious so I tried to give them
it's more of what you call a sound a
motif real simple element just a few
notes or an orchestration or a feel that
identifies them but it isn't getting
into like a whole big fleshed out theme
within a section of the B section and
all that it's more just an element that
your ear can catch and then I tried to
create a theme that is literally just a
Justice League theme that is about the
team that's about none of them
individually but is about the whole team
coming together
it it was fun but it was a huge puzzle
coming into it it was like like a
science project but there's a sequence
at the end that really I think was the
most fun for me where it ties all the
characters together and you have a
moment with each of the characters and
using a single thematic fool line and
time
together was I felt
my best accomplishment for bringing
something to the table
that's a peek inside the process of
scoring Justice League so don't miss the
movie event of the season this weekend
so you can experience how Danny Elfman's
brilliant work brings the team to life
justice league is going to be epic see
you guys tomorrow